[تصفيق]
حيثما يستشري الاستيطان تحتدم المواجهه في
الضفه الغربيه بين الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال والمستوطنين بنظره قريبه الى
جغرافيا الضفه يمكن تحديد بؤر الاشتباك
الاكثر اشتعالا جنوب نابلس حيث بلده حواره
وبورين عشرون مستوطنه وثلاثون بؤره
استيطانيه تلتهم محافظه نابلس تحديدا جنوب
المحافظه يضم هذا السياج مستوطنات براخا
ويتسار ورحليم ومجداليم وغيرها 40 الف
مستوطن تؤويهم هذه المستوطنات جلهم من
اليهود المتطرفين وجماعات تدفيع الثمن
شمال رام الله بؤره اشتباكات اخرى بين
الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين وقوات الاحتلال
حيث مستوطنه الشيلو المقامه على اراضي
بلدتي ترموسعيه والمغير والشيلو من
المستوطنات الدينيه حيث يقطنها مستوطنون
ينتمون الى اليمين المتطرف ما بين بيت لحم
والخليل يقع مفترق من هناك يمر
الاسرائيليون والفلسطينيون باستمرار لعده
اعوام وصف هذا المكان حيث مستوطنه
احد اخطر الاماكن في الضفه الغربيه وفي
قلب مدن الضفه تستشري بئر استيطانيه كما
في قلب الخليل حيث كريات اربع مستوطنات
جبل الخليل في ذاكره الفلسطينيه كان
للخليل ارث دام من جرائم المستوطنين
فكريات اربع توصف بانها وكر للحركه
العنصريه والمتطرفه كاخ التي اسسهانا
ومنها انطلق بروهكولدشتاين عام
1994 لينفذ مذبحه الحرم الابراهيمي وفي
كريات اربع يقيم وزير الامن القومي لتمرنج
فير صاحب مشروع قانون اعدام كل فلسطيني
ينفذ هجوما ضد اسرائيل